- I'm Yetur Gross-Matos.
I'm here with Bleacher Report
to pick my Super Bowl lineup.
[Upbeat music]
I gotta get Tom Brady.
You get Tom Brady, you already
going to the Super Bowl, so.
I'm gonna get Rob.
Can't nobody guard Rob.
Ed Reed, cuz Ed Reed was always one
of my favorite players to watch.
Lawrence Taylor, cuz he's different.
He's just a beast.
Um...
Man, this is hard.
I probably say Jerry Rice.
Can't guard Jerry Rice either, so.
I wanna add AP. I would.
But, I don't know, it's just...
[Upbeat music]
I can't, I can't not have
one of these on it, so.
[Upbeat music]
All right, I got Tom Brady, the GOAT.
Uh, Ed Reed, Jerry Rice
and Lawrence Taylor and Rob Gronkowski.
If you could find someone
who could stop Rob Gronkowski
or Lawrence Taylor,
you know, I'd pay you.
And then Jerry Rice,
most receiving yards.
Ed Reed, that's just my
favorite safety all-time, so.
And then Tom Brady, the GOAT.
Yetur Gross-Matos,
and I just built my
all-time Super Bowl squad.